Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
for that new marvel Wandavision post credit scene
that they just added everyone's wondering what's
going on there are a lot of questions you had so
i'll explain why they added a new post credit
scene and what's actually going on here because
fans are seeing a bunch of extra stuff that they
added in stuff that they removed and some other
weird stuff that you guys have asked me about
that you think might be a huge easter egg for dr
strange or white vision or something else i'm sure
everyone's queuing up all their mephisto jokes no
it's definitely not mephisto it's actually
surprisingly easy to explain so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos and obviously spoiler warning
for Wandavision if you have not seen the episode
yet because we'll be talking about everything that
happened in the post-credits scene but a couple
days ago some eagle-eyed fans on reddit spotted
that marvel had added a brand new version of the
post-credits scene just completely changing a
couple things in a very noticeable way there are
some things that are less noticeable than others
but if you slow the video down you zoom in in
hands on this part of the frame you notice that
there's a silhouette in the top left corner of the
frame that seems like it's floating down towards
the cabin here as the camera zooms in on scarlet
witch then as the camera moves in closer to her
inside the cabin to reveal what seems like her
in the astral plane reading from the dark hole
the doctor strange theme music spins up and
one of the other changes that fans notice is
they added michael giaccino's name to the credits
for the doctor strange theme his name wasn't in
the original version of the credits the other
changes that they made to the new version of
this post credit scene is they altered some
of the color correction so just everything
looks a little bit different color they changed a
little bit of the animation on the dark hole that
scarlet witch is reading from it and it seems like
they gave a polish an upgrade to make everything
look a little more complete better in general
like they also got rid of some ducks here covering
this part up of the lake r.i.p ducks the ducks
did nothing wrong and if you look really hard
you might notice that they also got rid of a light
that was shining through this window when we're
still outside the door zooming in slowly past this
version of scarlet witch to the other one inside
so there are a bunch of reasons why marvel changes
their movies and tv shows after they release them
tv studios in general will change scenes after
they've already released something movie studios
all the time just see the long list of edits that
george lucas made to the original star wars movie
in fun fact even though everyone always talks
about getting the de-specialized versions of
star wars the very first change that he ever made
to the original star wars movie in new hope was
when it was during opening weekend in 1977 after
the movie had been in theaters for a day or two
just to fix a couple editing errors that they
didn't notice when they had to ship the movie
because they were on a hard deadline marvel did
the exact same thing with avengers end game when
it first came out in theaters multi-billion dollar
film even though it just got knocked off the top
of the list by avatar again because of the avatar
re-release james cameron's revenge but when they
originally released the Wandavision finale episode
a couple months ago they said they were working to
finish right up until the last minute so a lot
of the episode post-production and whatnot was
very very rushed and as happens with a lot of
movies like avengers end game they continued to
edit the episode and just quietly swap in the new
version with whatever changes they made whatever
corrections they made when avengers end game was
first released in theaters if you didn't notice it
the first few days there were people that started
to notice small editing errors during the final
battle scene because they had to release the movie
without being completely done polishing everything
and there was so many special effects in that
film but like i said movie studios do this
all the time with really big movies especially
when they have a really tight window for a
release schedule tv is no different but more to
the Wandavision post-credit scene changes as sad
as you are i'm sure about the ducks that had to
die so that the Wandavision finale could live
everyone's still wondering what that weird
silhouette was was it supposed to be doctor
strange or white vision or something like that why
would they add that to the episode if they were
changing so many other things about this scene
and yes there were a bunch of doctor strange
deleted scenes a whole deleted subplot that they
got rid of early on featuring benedict cumberbatch
just to speed run explain that whole plot he was
originally going to be the one responsible for
all the weird commercials we kept seeing during
the episodes and they were going to be his way
of trying to communicate with wanda to get her to
realize what was really going on inside the hex
originally doctor strange would have shown up
on screen in a cameo by the time they got past
the nexus commercial in episode 7. then after
she became full scarlet witch goes final boss
form defeats her takes down the hex permanently
says goodbye to heck's vision billy and tommy
then doctor strange would have taken the darkhold
into custody for safekeeping scarlet witch would
have gone with him to study more of her magic and
they would have prepared for the events of doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness whereas the way
elizabeth olsen tells it in the final version
of the post-credits scene they played a little
more like wanda ran off before doctor strange
could show up to hold her accountable for what
she did low great enslaving an entire town for
a week no joke elizabeth olsen was actually
saying that she thought of scarlet witch as
a fugitive from the law like she actually would
have been arrested if she stuck around without
flying off and they will address what she did with
the hex during doctor strange 2 so with all these
big plans they had for doctor strange for the
series that's why fans were going crazy when they
saw this weird silhouette on the screen but here's
the thing if you've ever done any editing for film
or television or even for youtube videos for
that matter or have any experience in photoshop
what seems like happened with this silhouette is
that it was actually created as a side effect of
some of the other changes they were making
in this scene and it itself is just another
editing error so for instance when they got rid of
the light in this window no idea why they wanted
to get rid of it it seems like it was fine in the
original version but it seems like the editor used
a mask to get rid of it just a filter to hide this
light but then when they were finishing the other
edits they forgot to adjust the filter so that
it only showed up for these frames when the light
itself they were trying to cover was showing on
screen so it's like they just left the filter on
for the entire video so the filter to hide this
light actually shows up earlier here and if you
track the motion of this silhouette it tracks to
the location of where the light is they're trying
to cover up so it really does seem like just an
editing error that was created when they were
fixing these other things changing these other
things in the episode from the original version
and what will probably happen because everybody's
been talking about these changes the past couple
of days is that marvel will eventually notice
the new error here if they haven't already
hopefully they won't fire the editor that made
this new error and then quietly fix it swap in
a third version of this post-credit scene without
telling anyone so if you come back in another week
or two you probably won't be able to see this
silhouette anymore it's not meant to be a big
secret or anything like that this kind of stuff
happens more often than you'd think on all tv
shows and movies where you work on a super quick
deadline but marvel's policy in the past is to
just not mention when they make changes to little
things like this they'd only say something if you
could clearly see benedict cumberbatch in the
flesh on screen and the whole reason why they
added michael giaccino's name to the credits
for the doctor strange theme as you probably
suspected is because they use the doctor
strange theme music in the original version
of the post-credits scene i talked about
it in my original post-credits scene video
it was meant to be the big teaser saying oh this
is meant to be a moment foreshadowing setting
up the doctor strange 2 movie but they didn't
credit him in that version of the episode his
name didn't appear in the credits and legally
they have to do that it's in their contract
like the person who wrote the credits literally
just forgot to put his name in the first time
personally i have no idea why marvel waited
this long to make the changes to the episode
maybe they added it a while ago and fans just
noticed it now like i haven't re-watched the
Wandavision finale or at least this part of the
Wandavision finale that closely in a while so they
could have changed it a couple weeks ago and we
just didn't notice till now and i have no idea why
somebody at disney hated those ducks so much and
wanted to get rid of them but apparently they did
so rip ducks hopefully that explains what's
going on though why everybody was so confused
it's just that when stuff like this breaks on
twitter people go crazy and if you weren't an
editor for broadcast or you're not a big youtube
video editor you probably wouldn't recognize when
there's like a filter error or rendering error in
frame it's not meant to be them adding a secret
invisible doctor strange 2 the ending they have
finished filming the dr strange 2 movie though so
we'll probably see that first trailer attached to
the eternals movie when that comes out in november
because doctor strange 2 is coming out in march
next year right after spider-man no way home
benedict cumberbatch is going to be a big
character during spider-man no way home he'll
be at least critical for the plot but because the
way they pitched him in the movie is that he's
sort of replacing tony stark iron man as a mentor
to spider-man he'll probably only have about as
many scenes as iron man did during spider-man
homecoming which isn't that much but when he
does show up he'll be critical to the plot and
because they're spinning up into a multiverse of
madness it'll probably have something to do with
the spider-verse elements of the film with the
multiverse elements i don't know if scarlet witch
is also supposed to show up during spider-man
no way home maybe they'll address her during a
post-credits scene or something like that i don't
think she's supposed to show up during the actual
film itself the same way that benedict cumberbatch
is and yes they will release a spider-man no
way home trailer later this summer when it is
released of course i'll make all the videos for
it do not worry make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss it my full
loki episode 4 video will post wednesday too
i believe i'm allowed to post my black widow
review sometime tomorrow so that video should be
up pretty soon but if you have any other questions
leave them in the comments below or video requests
everyone click here for my video about all
the other Wandavision finale deleted scenes
and alternate endings and click here for
my full loki episode 3 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!